We have the expression (2x + 4) (5x - 9) = αx ^ 2 + bx - 36.
We have to find what a and b will be.
I recommend that you pause the video and try to find it yourself.
There are several ways to deal with this
and the simplest is to multiply the two single members on the left side
and see we can link members and odds.
Let's multiply the left side.
There are several ways to do that.
I prefer to consider it as applying the distribution property twice.
The expression on the left can be written as ...
One way to do this is to uncover braces and multiply
(2x + 4) at (5x - 9).
This is the same as (2x + 4) at 5x plus (2x + 4) by -9.
Or we could write it this way.
This is 5x by (2x + 4).
And we can see this as plus -9 or only as minus 9.
Minus 9 in (2x4).
All we did was reveal the brackets and multiply (2x + 4) by (5x - 9).
Okay, now that we've written it this way, looking at 5x by (2h + 4),
we see that we can multiply by 5x.
We can multiply 5x by (2x + 4).
How much is 5x by 2h?
This is 10 x 2,
5x by 4 is plus 20x.
And then we have -9 at 2x = -18x.
Minus 18h.
And then you got -9 at 4, which is -36.
And now we can simplify it.
We have two first degree members.
We have 10x ^ 2
and then these two first degree members,
let me surround them ...
We have these two first degree members.
If I have 20x and get out of them 18x,
will stay 2h.
20x minus 18x is two x.
And then, of course, we still have -36.
Everything I've done so far is
simplify or convert the left side.
However, we must remember that this is an equation,
so this should be equal to the right side.
This is equal to αx2 + bx -36.
And now, after writing it in appropriate colors, you can think of what a and b will be.
On the left we have 10x ^ 2, and on the right the member of the second degree is αx ^ 2.
So 10 should be equal to a.
These two factors must be equal.
We can write that a is equal to 10.
And then we look at the first grade member.
Here we have 2h, and here we have bh.
So 2 should be equal to b
or b must be equal to 2.
And it turns out that free members
are the same on both sides.
So we decided it, but it is equal to 10, b equals 2.
Now that you have exercised enough on this, you might want to ask:
"Is there a faster way to do this?"
Even though you're more likely to do it
inadvertent errors.
You can ask:
"How do I get a square?"
How, when I multiply these,
do i get a square? "
The only way to get x in a square
is to multiply 2x by 5x.
And this is 10x square.
And then you can ask: "Well, it's equal to 10.
But how do I find x? "
There are two ways to find x.
You can multiply 2x by minus 9.
This is minus 18x.
Or you can multiply 4 by 5x,
which is plus 20x.
If you put them together,
they will be equal to 2h.
Therefore, 2x = bx,
b must be equal to 2.
And then you can just check ...
how will you get the free member?
Well, you have to multiply the two free members.
4 in 9 and you will get -36.
The second way I've just decided,
is a little faster, but
you are more likely to make a mistake inadvertently.
I hope you understand,
that they actually do the same thing.
Perhaps with different degrees of clarity.